[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zu sallys welt ich
finde es ist mal wieder zeit für ein
motiv torte ich glaube die letzte große
motiv torte war tatsächlich die harry
potter torte und jetzt wer den sommer
habe ich mir gedacht was mache ich denn
da im sommer back ich eigentlich nicht
so gerne motiv torten denn bei uns
gibt's ja irgendwie kein anlass ich habe
zwar im august geburtstag aber ich mag
mir nicht selber motiv torte und die
kinder haben alle winter und murat im
herbst also gibt es heute trotzdem
einfach außerhalb der reihe meine motiv
torte ich habe das gesehen und zwar weil
das heißt auf japanisch süß und es gibt
auch diese speziellen zeichnungen samira
zeichnet ist auch immer ganz gerne
also so eine ananas hieß es aussieht
oder der wassermelone mit seiner kleinen
augen dran und es ist irgendwie so eine
ganz eigene kunst und ich dachte mir ich
nehme das jetzt als inspiration und ba
keine covermotiv torte als motiv habe
ich mir eine ananas ausgewirkt
diese anders die backe ich jetzt mit
augen dran und ich glaube das ist eine
ziemlich süße motiv torte dem mann zum
geburtstag verschenken kann oder auch
einfach mal wenn man es sommer hawaii
party schmeißt vielleicht sogar eine
pool-party wenn man am pool hat und dann
kann man diese motiv torte backen
so stelle ich mir das vor oder einfach
so wenn man muss drauf hat und weil man
sich es findet also die anderen
achtstellige zu hilfe denn die sieht sie
es aus ja man sieht sie nicht
die anderer stelle hier rein
sie schlägt so perfekt hier habe ich
glaube ich weiß nicht woher der name
kommt jedenfalls back ich jetzt ich habe
eine umfrage gemacht
ob ihr ananas und kokos mögt also so
pina colada
denn jetzt werde ich eine pina colada
torte backen wenn ihr sagt ich bin da
nicht so der fan davon dann machst du
einfach einen schoko boden zum beispiel
eine schoko creme da gibt es ja schon
bereits ganz viele rezepte auf meinem
kanal dann könnt ihr die torte trotzdem
backen aber mit anderen inhalt ich
brauche für den teig sechs eier diesen
bereits zimmer war eine prise salz 300
etwas vanille extrakt jeweils 300 gramm
sonnenblumen
buttermilch 450 gramm mehl 200 gramm
kokosraspeln und ein päckchen backpulver
das sind drei teelöffel ich nehme jetzt
erst die eier die kommen in die
rührschüssel gemeinsam mit dem zucker
und salz und von den extrakt es neigt
sich dem ende zu und dann verrät ihr die
masse für etwa fünf bis sieben minuten
bis sie schön weiß cremig jetzt
[Musik]
guckt euch das war so schön cremig
gerührt ich habe ich jetzt schon 2 back
ringe auf 18 cm durchmesser eingestellt
und mit backpapier eingeschlagen denn
das ist ein sehr fleißiger teig und 18
cm deswegen weil die torte schön hoch
werden soll und was würde ich noch um
zwei ringe deswegen weil einfach das
viel masse ist und ich habe eine kürzere
bauzeit und eben auch gleichmäßiger
daher die 23 jetzt könnt ihr die zwei
flüssigkeiten hier dazugeben und
buttermilch statt butter milch könnt ihr
auch wenn jetzt keine kinder mit essen
und ihr nichts dagegen habt könnt ihr
auch zum beispiel batida de coco dazu
geben also ein bisschen kokos likör
buttermilch macht den teig einfach so
mega mega saftig zutaten rühre ich kurz
ein und dann kommen schon die trockenen
dazu und wenn ihr den kokons geschmack
verstecken wollt könnt ihr die
kokosraspeln auch in der pfanne ein
bisschen rösten
ich lasse jetzt allerdings so denn so
schmeckt auch schon sehr gut das hat man
einfach so sondern die hosta roma mit
drin
mehl und backpulver und jetzt nur noch
so lange verrührt bis sich alles gut
verbunden hat
der teig sind einfach so gut aus und
jetzt teile ich denn hier auf und füllt
ihn ein
jetzt dürft ihr den teig gern so ein
bisschen am rand hoch streichen
so geht dann noch gleichmäßiger auf und
dann wird er schon gebacken
ok
guckt mal wie perfekt der kuchen jetzt
einfach aussieht
ich habe die stäbchen probe gemacht das
bedeutet ihr nehmt einen zahnstocher
steckt ihn neben mitte des tages also am
backofen des kuchens nicht des tages
denn jetzt ist kein tag nicht und wenn
dann nichts mehr dran kleben bleibt
unser fertig da noch ein krümel dran
aber das war okay es war nichts feuchtes
mehr dran
so las ich denn jetzt abkühlen und werde
in der zwischenzeit mich schon mal um
die ananas gehören ist nämlich gerade
eingefallen wisst ihr was jetzt machen
werde
ein ananas curt sowie elemente an anders
gehört und elegisch einfach ein tuch
drauf da kannst schön abkühlen und nach
dem abkühlen kommt es noch mal in den
kühlschrank den kühlschrank kalter
kuchen lässt sich einfach viel besser
schnell für das anders curt nehme ich
jetzt eine ananas zweier habe ich noch
etwas zucker stärke und butter die
genauen mengen schreibe ich euch dann
einfach in die app beziehungsweise in
einem blog denn ich weiß noch nicht ob
sie passen ich probier's einfach auf
eine ananas erkennt also die reife
ananas erkennt ihr übrigens daran gibt's
supermarkt oder zum wochenmarkt meistens
sind sie ja schon es reif und werden
auch reif angeboten aber ihr könnt mal
schauen denn manche brauchen einfach
noch mal ein zwei tage unternehmt ihr
hier oben diese blätter und wenn die
sich leicht lösen lassen
dann ist die ananas reif also kannst du
dir mit denen der mitte ich will jetzt
nicht alle raus ziehen reicht die
anderen aus versehen sind vielleicht
braucht nur die späte fürs foto noch und
daran erkennt ihr es ist jetzt noch
recht kleine und ich nehme jetzt hier
den weg
jetzt können dass einzelne messer
einfach schälen oder ich einen ananas
schneider
was ich ganz praktisch fünf vor allem
weil bei uns die total gerne an anders
ist das kann man das nämlich hier so
rein drehen und entweder hör dir dann
früher aufzudrehen und könnt dann das
noch als gefäß benutzen
ich glaube das machen sie sich doch
einfach wasser rein und dann kann die
ella minx strohhalm daraus trinken rät
jetzt ist auch noch ob bislang alles
drin
aber wie gesagt das passt und die mitte
hätte könnt ihr aufnehmen
schneide ich jetzt mit einem messer raus
denn da stecken auch ganz ganz viele
vitamine drin
die meisten essens nur nicht weil der
strunk einfach erst ein bisschen holzig
auch ist von der textur her
aber wie gesagt stehe man am start macht
mit dass da nix oder in einem smoking
so wie gesagt das lasse ich jetzt für
die ella und dieser mehrerer kleiner
muss ich jetzt gar nicht denn ich werde
direkt pürieren
ich wünsche mir jetzt nur kurz ab dann
kann ich euch direkt die ananas menge
perfekt aufschreiben
ich habe ich noch was übrig vom letzten
mal
es geht jetzt hier einfach noch die eier
mit rein denn dann muss ich nichts
klümpchen frei berühren sondern kann
direkt alles so vermischen
außerdem butter die kommen zum schluss
dazu
und jetzt alles fein für ihren strom
strombach
jetzt kommt die mischung in einen topf
und dann könnt ihr sie bei mittlerer
hitze unter ständigem rühren einmal kurz
aufkochen lassen und ein lamm anhört ist
auch super lecker und das ist zum einen
eine richtig leckere torten füllung oder
ihr könnt damit auch quark verrühren
oder das ganze wie so eine art marmelade
auf brot genießen
also echt mega lag hat es mache ich
total gerne hätte ich jetzt einen
größeren topf nehmen soll
nehmt einen größeren topf bitte ich
spreche aus erfahrung habe ich lerne
mich da raus
waghäusel stabil junge
[Musik]
logisch da
oh mein gott wer kennst hätte bitte
stellt mich tgv ich will mit teddy
backen
aber da muss er einmal für mich den
freddy mercury machen
ich liebte das video nun sogar samira
und ella feiern
bitte kommen und backen mit mir
ich packte auch wasserkocher ist das
hier war wird kann ich auch schon mal
gern mixa reinigen und zwar einige ich
so ein blender immer etwas spülmittel
rhein bei mir jetzt noch ein spritzer
essig da ich ja noch drin hatte und
wasser und dann mixen und dann wird der
länder schon von alleine sagt er ist
aber nicht zu hören habe ich gerne
stunde essig wieder werk aber macht es
natürlich ich bin echt also ich glaube
ich muss mal meine nase irgendwie
schwierig einfach dieses ich kann es
nicht und dann muss ich immer als sie
beziehungsweise essigessenz benutzen um
den golf zu neutralisieren
[Musik]
jetzt ist die masse aufgekocht
guckt mal und auch eingedeckt jetzt
normalerweise würde ich sie noch durch
ein sieb streichen aber ich muss sagen
aber ich muss sagen ich hatte jetzt
sowieso pariert hat streiche ich jetzt
nicht mehr durch aber wenn er die
anderen hafen ist so ganz fein bekommt
und die alte nach erste zug mit der
stärke auf jeden fall durch sieben damit
eben keine klümpchen entstehen und ja es
ist ihr umfeld und jetzt eben auch
schnell abkühlen kann
dann steht jetzt auch probieren ich hab
das zum ersten mal gemacht
ich konnte immer nur so lernen gehört
wird jetzt dachte ich wie kriege ich die
anderen ausstellung in die torte man in
der frucht einlage und irgendwie kam so
und jetzt die kalte butter dazu dadurch
kühlt das ganze natürlich altmark
schnell ab und dann spielt jetzt am
besten in marmeladengläsern ab und durch
abkühlen wird natürlich auch für eine
konsistenz her fester es ist jetzt nicht
so lange haltbar wie marmelade zum einen
weil ich wenig wenig zucker drin habe
und zum anderen hatte ich auch weniger
meilern und der botschaft also eine
woche im kühlschrank geht auf jeden fall
aber länger sollte jetzt nicht
aufbewahren performer kurz zwei löffel
und ich bin ein fan davon dass die
füllung jetzt hoffentlich nicht zu süß
ist damit die torte ausgleicht
geschmacklich vorsicht heiß
und durch das erhitzen passiert
folgendes wenn ihr jetzt ananas mit
joghurt von mir stand es bitter als auch
annas im müsli zum beispiel wird peter
woda smoothie miteinanders und milch
wird bitter weil einfach alles was uns
enzym hat war es eben mit milch und
milchprodukten reagiert und dann wird
dieser bittere geschmack av gerufen aber
durch erhitzen geht es kaputt
und jetzt kann ich diese torte ganz wie
ich möchte zum beispiel auch mit quark
vermischen also diese dieser masse und
dann habt ihr das eben nicht mehr also
erhitzen und dann gibt es auch bei kiwi
so oder anders aus der dose
also alles packt ich finde es jetzt
unseren tags abkühlen und dann kümmere
ich mich eigentlich schon um die creme
[Musik]
hier habe ich die zutaten für die
buttercreme ich mache jetzt eine swiss
bank batterien
ihr könnt auch eine italienische
buttercreme machen oder eine
französische buttercreme ich mache das
jetzt hier als eiweiß resteverwertung
weil ich einfach noch ganz viel übrig
hatte ich verwende dafür eiweiß zucker
salz
hier habe ich noch etwas kokos creme
mutter und bruder zu kommen bei der coco
stream habe ich einfach so gemacht ich
habe eine dose kokosmilch verwendet
nicht geschüttelt
denn das setzt es ist ja dieser fettige
bestandteil also das ist eine
60-prozentige kokosmilch setzt sich dann
oben ab und dann dürften die schütteln
und schöpft es einfach weg und so
bekommt er in dieser buttercreme einfach
noch kokos geschmack mittragen ich mache
ich jetzt zum ersten mal ich teste es
ist einfach wichtig ist jetzt bei der
butter kleben nur dass das eiweiß mit
dem salz und zucker verrührt und erwärmt
wird
das könnt ihr entweder über einem warmen
wasserbad machen also im topf mit wasser
darüber dass schüssel und dann wirklich
zehn minuten lang über dem kochenden
wasser bat erwärmen oder in der
küchenmaschine stellt die auf 70 grad
ein und erwarb es dort für zehn minuten
so mache ich jetzt weil es schneller
einfacher wird
[Musik]
hier also einfach die zutaten rhein
geben dann werde ich hier 70 grad und
las auf etwa stufe drei bis vier rühren
bei 60 grad schaltet sich die maschine
automatisch updaten zusatzfunktionen und
dann trete ich hier einfach auf den klub
damit die maschine weiß da ist jemand da
und dann schlägt eben auch wieder uns
gut feiern jetzt einfach hier drauf
drücken und dann kommt die
geschwindigkeit wieder zurück
die masse erwärmt ist auf sechs grad und
wenn sie dann 70 grad warm ist dann
zähle ich die zehn minuten und dann
schaue ich aber die hitze ab dh das ist
auch der moment an dem ihr praktisch das
eiweiß vom wasserbad unternimmt und dann
muss es kalt gerührt werden
es dauert und auch immer so etwa 10 15
bis 20 minuten
je nach außentemperatur und so lange
hol ich von ganz denn wir können gleich
schon mit deko herstellung während die
eismasse jetzt noch kalt wird kann ich
jetzt schon mal die butter gemeinsam mit
der coco stream und im puderzucker
richtig schön weiß cremig spüren es
dauerte etwa fünf bis sechs minuten
[Musik]
wenn die eismasse dann wieder kalt
gerührt ist und die butter masse weich
gerührt ist werden beiden komponenten
verbunden
[Musik]
und diese konsistenz bekommt ihr
wirklich nur hin wenn das eiweiß schon
wieder kalt gerührt ist und die butter
wirklich schön zimmer warm war
flauschig fluffig und schaumig gerührt
wurde und jetzt habt ihr einfach die
perfekte buttercreme
[Musik]
torten wurden ist stabil junge und dann
werden die böden mit einer trotten säge
durchgeschnitten so dünn wie ihr sie
haben möchtet ach das passt perfekt ich
hab sie gedrittelt
ich wollte eigentlich noch diese diesen
funden strunk machen aber ich kann noch
nicht dazu denn ich habe mich dazu
entschlossen zwischendrin noch pizza zu
machen für mich etwas zu essen haben und
dann muss halt der stromnetze warten
[Musik]
jetzt kenne ich die torte föhnig für
selbst und stapelte erst mal auf so
einem carport
da kann ich sie nämlich auch wunderbar
weg heben damit darauf jetzt nicht so
sehr rutscht einfach zum befestigen
etwas butter kriegen dann den ersten
boden draufsetzen
wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr die böden
jetzt auch gern noch mal mit batida de
coco trinken
aber sie sind auch so schon super saftig
da gebe ich jetzt mein ananas kurz drauf
wenn ihr das ein bisschen fester haben
wollt gibt ja einfach bisschen mehr
butter dazu denn die botschaft die
bindet das ganze eher um macht dann
ebenso streichfähig cremig aber ich
finde so jetzt von der konsistenz recht
gut
die streiche ziehe eine dünne schicht er
drauf darüber eine dünne schicht
buttercreme muss jetzt noch gucken dass
die nicht rutscht
theoretisch könnte auch beides verbinden
dann kommt der nächste boden drauf und
so füllt ihr jetzt die gesamte torte
[Musik]
verpasst und jetzt mache ich so nicht
reeßum und setzten auch den anderen
deckel unten dran dann habe ich schon
mal die zwei rundungen
deshalb ist wackelig aus ich weiß ich
habe ein bisschen angst weil sie noch so
düster was ich cool sehr ernst und dann
setze ich den boden dran denn die creme
muss erst einmal fest werden
jetzt die torte gekühlt ich habe sie
übrigens noch mit dem meer tortenring
einfach ein bisschen stabilisiert vor
allem trocknet sie dann auch nicht aus
also ich las torten eigentlich nie ein
abgedeckt im kühlschrank außer sie haben
schon eine fondant schichten
jetzt kann ich die torte auf den kopf
drehen da funktioniert wird sich dort
tatsächlich in spiegelschrift und hier
mache ich nicht so
damit die optik später auch passt denn
jetzt die stadt herum gedreht
jetzt kommt hier die krokos buttercreme
weil der kleine morgen gehen mir sagt
jetzt kann ich ein anderer strom machen
das musste gleicher optik dann die creme
die ananas creme und die kommt hier hin
da dam
hervorragend und zack
und jetzt ist der tag leider schon sehr
fortgeschritten ich hätte heute noch
gerne weitergemacht aber wer hat soviel
zwischen reingemacht
das ist jetzt schon wieder 18 uhr 30
wurde deswegen habe ich die torte jetzt
einfach morgen weiter ist sicherer für
uns alle und die rechtliche buttercreme
die kommt in den kühlschrank die nehme
ich morgen dann kurz vor heraus dann
kann ich sie nochmal verrühren und schon
ist ja auch wieder gescheitert heute ist
der nächste tag man sieht man sieht dass
oder ich bin einen tag älter geworden
er war aber wir haben uns alle jungen
gehalten
jedenfalls ist die torte noch in der
kühlung damit mache ich gar nicht weiter
ich möchte jetzt aber zuerst einmal den
strunk der ananas machen ich hoffe das
heißt auch strom
ich denke schon dafür verwende ich
grünen fondant das ist eine zucker über
zugs maße die man eben ganz gerne zum
dekorieren von torten verwendet und die
ist aber schön weich das heißt wenn ihr
diese über die torte legt so wie es auch
später machen werde mit dem gelben
fondant dann bleibt sie weich und ist ja
auch gut so denn man möchte die torte
anschneiden und auch essen dann gibt es
hier noch blüten passte und das ist die
paste die bei luft austrocknet das heißt
wenn ihre blüten modelliert oder figuren
oder so wie ich jetzt den strunk der da
oben auch schön stehen soll dann
verwendet ihr blöden passte und wenn ihr
diese beiden zusammen mit entsteht
modelliermasse wenn er keine blüten
passte habt könnt ihr auch zellulose
pulver nehmen also cmc nennt sich das
dann und dann gebt ihr einfach pro 200
250 gramm von damit ungefähr einen
teelöffel dazu und das bewegt dann eben
auch dass die masse aushärtet also so
viel zur theorie denn wenn ihr jetzt nur
den von hand nimmt und den strunk macht
dann wegen sich die blätter nicht also
die bleiben nicht so sondern machen und
das wäre schade also das jetzt gut
zusammen kneten
ich muss jetzt mal gucken ich glaube ich
hab's dann noch ein bisschen nach
denn jetzt habe ich eher so ein pastell
grün aber ich will sowieso 23 farben
haben
daher fühle ich mich ganz kurz grüne
verpasste also ich nehme noch bis in
gelb und etwas grün und ihr könnt eure
hände immer gerne mit kokosfett ein
bisschen einfetten dann ist das kneten
nämlich einfach alles was ihr nicht
verwendet einfach schön luftdicht
verpacken damit nicht austrocknet und
wenn ihr dann eure wunsch farbe habt
also immer berücksichtigen es wird immer
noch ein bisschen dunkler wenn es dann
eben wieder kalt wird durch das kneten
wird einfach mit den heller und dann
eben wieder dunkler beim aushärten
dann könnt ihr jetzt mit becker stärke
die masse ausrollen becker stärke ist
eine stärke aus kartoffeln und die klebt
nicht und ihr seht doch ganz schön sie
ist so ganz fein und man kann sie später
eben schon wieder weg futtern
also dann rolle ich das jetzt hier nicht
aus denn jetzt kommt noch strukturen und
guckt die bäcker stärke die bekommt ihr
ganz einfach wieder weg es gab mit
puderzucker mit speisestärke nicht daher
rate ich euch wirklich becker stärke zum
ausrollen zu benutzen
und jetzt nehmen die entweder solche
ausstecher dem eigentlich eine schöne
form erinnert auch wirklich an dieses
ananas blatt oben oder in ihm dein
marzipan messer also ein stumpfes messer
und könnt euch einfach hier
diese form ausschneiden ich brauche
jetzt einfach mal die sind schon recht
klein aber ich brauche kleine und große
vielleicht schon eigentlich ein paar
noch händisch dann aus könnte sogar das
hier noch so eindrücken aber ich mache
gleich noch struktur rein auf jeden fall
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich große und kleine blätter
und schneidet hier einfach noch welche
mit hilfe des platz aus jetzt könnt ihr
die blätter noch strukturieren zum
beispiel mit so einem stumpfen werkzeug
einfach so ein paar streifen reinziehen
dass das ganze einfach lebendiger wird
im moment die eine richtung also zur
spitze hin so und dann werde ich glaube
ich die blätter nach oben hin so ein
bisschen ausdünnen
ja das sieht gut aus nach oben hin aus
dann überlege ich klasse die anderen
sagen dann müssen sie sich so gegen ich
glaube dann gehe ich sehr einfach ein
bisschen raus raus starb und du hast du
so bist ja das ist so
[Musik]
ich habe die blätter von der vorder und
rückseite strukturiert damit man eben
von beiden seiten der struktur hat und
jetzt fange ich an diesen strunk zu
formen ich nehme es erstmal die großen
blätter
ich habe mir die auch so ein bisschen
sortiert dann werden sie in der mitte ja
eigentlich fast zusammen geknickt da
kommt etwas essbarer kleber rein aber
nur hier unten und ich bin mir jetzt
einfach das zum stabilisieren
also dann versuche ich die jetzt auch so
halb zu überlassen also dass in der
mitte lasse ich so und dann glaub ich
dort so mache ich das so gut und setzt
sich da wieder so das halbe dran das ist
schon mal dass ihnen leben
es ist noch zu weich
ich glaube ich muss sie antrocknen
lassen bei den kleinen clubs ist gut die
stehen auch fertig großen dem muss man
schon ein bisserl antrocknen lassen
naja ich lass dir noch trocknen und dann
kleben
aber die kleinen gibt es schon mal so
ein bisschen hin
und die großen de lege ich mir auch so
irgendwo darüber mit dieser mit diesem
knick unten und der biegung hier oben
nach außen
und wenn sie dann ein bisschen an
getrocknet sind dann lassen sie sich
auch kleben
ich habe ich jetzt noch ein stück blüten
passte einfach ausgerollt ich stecke
jetzt einfach noch ein paar blüten aus
ich weiß nicht ob ich das später
benutzer aber ich glaube es kommt ganz
süß aussehen und damit die sich jetzt
schön formen also normalerweise würde
ich sie jetzt noch mit einem rollstuhl
aus dünnen das ist ein bisschen
realistischer aussehen aber ich finde
dieses cover dieser kar wais weil lebt
davon dass es so comic mäßig aus süd und
jetzt lege ich dass ich hier einfach in
so einer schalen rein
die wirtin mal ich glaube in meinem
kühlschrank mitgeliefert und schlägt da
meine eier mir ein an diesen eiswürfel
behälter genau weil das hat seinen
deckel und ich mache darin aber keine
eiswürfel also benutze ich dafür
und dann haben sie eine schöne runde
also wenn ihr mit einem gold hole hier
in der mitte
diese rundung einfach noch ein bisschen
vertieft dann habt ihr so in sich
gewählte blätter also gar nicht so den
rand aus den und sondern einfach die
blätter in sich weil
[Musik]
blumen kann man nie genug haben und dann
lasse ich die blüten einfach trocknen
die werden später noch schön pudert mit
etwas lebensmittelfarbe und dann kann
ich eigentlich schon mit der torte
weitermachen
weiter geht es mit der torte
sie hatte im prinzip fast schon die
perfekte form
ich denke unten kann ich noch ein
bisschen der rundung einschneiden so
dass er unten eben nicht so flach runter
geht sondern vielleicht abgerundet es
ist einfach so ein kleines messer
ansetzen hier unten diese ecke wegnehmen
ein kleiner schritt für mich aber ein
großer für die optik des kuchen beiträgt
ist ein minimaler schritt aber er macht
es dann aus das ist so das detail ich
kann ja mal gucken ich streiche jetzt
erstmal ein
und dann schaue ich einfach ob ich hier
die form so lasse oder nochmal nach
schneide ich nehme hier ein bisschen von
der buttercreme und ihr könnt die torte
jetzt entweder komplett mit der
buttercreme einstreichen denn dieser
fondant tauglich also da muss man
einfach darauf achten dass der fondant
nicht in berührung mit sahne creme zum
beispiel kommt oder die deutsche
buttercreme mit pudding die funktioniert
auch nicht ist einfach zu viel
flüssigkeit und feuchtigkeit drin
diese buttercreme funktioniert oder auch
die französische oder auch ghanas und
ich guck mal heute jetzt nämlich ein
sehr warmer tag und da finde ich es
oftmals einfach besser wenn außen noch
eine schicht kanal strom ist die schweiz
nämlich nicht so schnell wie butter und
dann ist das verarbeiten immer einfach
dann habe ich jetzt hier schon mal die
erste schicht die bindet jetzt einfach
diese kuchen krümmel dass da nichts mehr
krümelt und ich später eine glatte
oberfläche habe bzw einen untergrund für
den fondant die torte stelle ich jetzt
noch mal in den kühlschrank für etwa 10
bis 20 minuten kann ihm der zwischenzeit
aufräumen vielleicht sogar schon den
strunk weitermachen und ich werde aber
später wirklich noch ein bisschen
ganache nehmen ich habe mich danach
eingefroren
dietrich ganz kurz auf ansonsten könnte
der weise kann auch selbst herstellen da
gibt es bereits ein grundrezept bei mir
hat mal jetzt in die blätter schön
angetrocknet nehmt euch wirklich auch
die zeit denn ich habe meine jetzt auch
noch mal frisch gemacht und jetzt kann
ich sie zusammen kleben die großen nach
innen wieder kleber auf eine seite und
immer die eine hälfte an die andere dran
kleben und dann schließt sich so der
innere kreis
[Musik]
nach außen hin werden dann die blätter
immer kleiner
aber oben hänge ich noch ein paar kleine
rein
denn die wachsen ja so keine ahnung wie
die ananas das macht aber sie wächst
sie wächst einfach und einfach beim
kleben darauf achten dass die blätter so
ein bisschen überlappen habe ich glaube
ich muss den inneren kreis es erst mal
stabil kleben stabil junge murats teglas
ist das perfekte ananas strom klaus ich
lass das jetzt richtig gut trocknen
diese blätter da macht es nichts wenn
die komplett durch trocknen
die kann ich später einfach noch
ankleben passt gut aber so erinnere part
der muss es schon gut trocknen
jetzt können die blätter euch noch so
hinlegen wie er sie braucht und lasst es
jetzt stehen
[Musik]
so wird sie ist sehr gut
und wie gesagt habe ich hier meine
garage einfach aufgetaut in einem topf
bei niedriger hitze und ich nehme es
jetzt erst einmal so weich wie sie ist
damit ich hier auch einmal eine basis
hat das sind nämlich hatte richtig angst
opfer und ich würde so gerne mal gehabt
direkt töpferwerkstatt also kennt ihr
vielleicht jemanden aus dem kreis
karlsruhe mannheim oder heidelberg dann
am ende doch ich den ich hab was
gefunden aber da war früher eine und
jetzt töpfern sie also da gibt es halt
keine kurse mehr sondern die töpfer nur
auf anfragen ob ich okay also die
kanalstrecke ziel fest ich stelle die
torte nochmal kühlen dieser ganache
stelle ich auch ganz kühl damit so ein
bisschen streichfähige wird und dann
werde ich die torte einfach einmal
komplett glätten und nehmen wir dazu
auch eine teig hatte damit auch daran
schön flach mit sobald die ganache die
perfekte konsistenz erreicht hat können
wir mit so einer flexiblen teig karte
wirklich richtig schön die oberfläche
glätten ihnen nur ganz wenigen
arbeitsschritten dann kann man sie so
ein bisschen zusammenrücken und hier
unten und oben die rundungen glätten so
echt wie beim töpfern
so kann ich mit der torte leben als es
jetzt schön glatt muss jetzt auch nicht
komplett perfekt sein
die kommt jetzt so in den kühlschrank
darf durch kühlen und dann kommt dann
nämlich die vom land decke drauf
vielleicht kann ich wieder am struck
weiter arbeiten
[Musik]
so kann es in der gewünschten form schön
durchtrocknen weiß auch echt ratsam wenn
ihr das macht bevor ihr die torte macht
denn je nach außentemperatur und
feuchtigkeit trocken jetzt mal besser
mal langsamer und wenn ihr das einfach
schon vorbereitet habt es kann auch
gerne zwei drei tage vorher schon sein
dann habt ihr einfach den sprung schon
mal sicher und habe nicht den stress wie
ich jetzt am gleichen tag noch durch
problem ist
wisst ihr was ich beschleunige die
trocknung stalker ich trockne zum ersten
mal von damp der automaten ist
eigentlich gehen ich kenne die
temperatur ganz präzise niedrig
einstellen und dann
[Musik]
jetzt ist die anderen strand und ich
habe jetzt hier drei päckchen gelben vom
band und weil mir davon dann zu gelb ist
für die ananas zumindest möchte ich
jetzt noch bisschen weiß rein
ich gucke jetzt mal dass es so ein
bisschen pastellige wird und später wird
es dann auch noch schockiert mit grün
da möchte ich einfach noch so grünen
farbverlauf habe und die farben die
lassen sich halt echt komischen
untereinander
[Musik]
die farbe gefällt mir sehr gut
und jetzt wird diese decke auch
ausgerollt und wenn ihr das nicht ganz
gleichmäßig hin bekommen könnt jetzt mit
den aus rom starb nehmen und entweder
teig hölzer benutzen oder einfach diese
abstands ringe mit 5 oder 3 mm je
nachdem wie das haben wollte denn dann
habt ihr ne schöne gleichmäßig dicke
rolf on.de wenn ihr durch das kneten so
kleine luftbläschen habt könnt ihr
einfach mit messer aufstechen ganz
vorsichtig die luft raus streichen und
nochmal drüber rollen dann sieht man
darf keine rückstände mehr
[Musik]
jetzt kommt ihr von der decke über die
torte die sprüche ist kurz mit back
trends 0 1 damit die oberfläche nicht so
trocken ist und der fondant eben auch
schön haftet das ist doch warum ich nur
zusammengestellt also hier in der küche
sie ist auch wirklich nur dafür gedacht
ich nämlich die bäcker stärke noch weg
dann einfach hier drüber legen und davon
dann ist auch wirklich schön elastisch
der ist mit shea butter
deswegen reist dann nicht so schnell
oder heute eigentlich fast gar nichts
und deswegen könnt ihr dann auch ruhig
so ein bisschen 10
und jetzt hier mit den händen flach
andrücken die eine hand nimmt immer die
front und deckel und drückt direkt oder
zieht sie weg und die andere hand drückt
sozusagen die luft und uns unser weg und
dann schmiegt sich das schön an ohne
falz ein paar rundungen unten ist echt
schwierig aber es klappt jetzt kann nur
noch ein mini und draus machen
die reste erst mal grob wegschneiden mit
so einem marzipan vom landmesser
und das könnte auch alles wunderbar
aufheben einfach nur luftdicht verpacken
und dann ist es wirklich mehrere monate
haltbar und jetzt erstmal die oberfläche
ist ein bisschen glätten die runde und
schön ausarbeiten
[Musik]
das habe ich mir hier eine theke gebaut
beziehungsweise eine erhöhung und die
ananas form finde ich so jetzt ganz gut
ich mache diese cover form also wenn ihr
eine richtig echte anders machen wollte
muss sie natürlich etwas höher sein und
dafür schlagen kann so wie die anderen
aus da hinten eben aber das war ja
langweilig jetzt kommen hier so
rautenmuster rein und ihr könnt ihr
entweder mit seinem marzipan messer zum
beispiel oder mit modelle werkzeug
einprägen ich habe jetzt hier
tatsächlich in meiner schublade sagt
hilfsmittel gebunden mit rauten dran und
probiert das jetzt aus und wenn es gut
ist dann nehme ich es im repertoire auf
und dann so von links nach rechts einmal
durch das kann ja auch prima benutzen
wenn man so stepp leder macht so oder so
ein kissen oder polster für seine
prinzessinnen torte also ich glaube
outen oder wie alt sie sind ein
oktoberfest direktion multitool
von der ananas zum oktoberfest wer
hätt's gedacht ja schluss gedacht und
hier unten fahrt ihr dann einfach mit so
einem modell werkzeug die linien bis
nach unten durch bis zur rundung und
david glaube ich perfekt also ich finde
den abschluss kann man hier oben
entweder so lassen oder einfach noch
weiter in die mitte ziehen das heißt man
macht einfach so ein muster ich probiere
es jetzt noch weitestgehend gleichmäßig
[Musik]
es ist so traurig ich mache eine
sahnetorte und dann sieht das wetter so
aus ich habe auch schon im winter neff
und dann tot gemacht und dann war die
sonne irgendwie wieder so heiße ware
wieder fast 30 grad in einer kirche ja
noch eine zweite runde oder lass ich so
eigentlich sieht so schon recht perfekt
aus ich muss sagen ich lasse so weil der
strom kommt ja noch perfekt was ich hier
noch mache um das ganze lebendiger zu
machen
ich finde schon echt ziemlich cool aber
wie gesagt will ich ja noch diese grüne
optik reinbringen die die ananas hat
nicht so stark dass er auch wirklich
noch diesen charakter hat deswegen
nämlich ein bisschen pulver farbe in
hellgrünen bisschen dunkelgrün ein wenig
orange und ein wenig geb
und dann einfach mit einem trockenen
pinsel in die farbe rein da muss ich
jetzt ein bisschen ausprobieren und dann
hier einfach diese linien nachfahren wie
gesagt oben mehr grün und unten dann
eher geld lassen
[Musik]
das ist so wo meine bk lehrerin meinte
mit der kundin springt weiter als im
kindergarten und dann komme ich unter t
[Musik]
cook steht jetzt der ananas strunk auf
richtig schön getrocknet und jetzt könnt
ihr auch ihr pulver farbe nehmen und
einfach so ein bisschen schockieren
ich finde das macht das ganze dann echt
so ein bisschen lebendiger und schöner
weil sich die prüfer farbe auch so ein
bisschen in die rillen einsetzt und
diese vertiefungen verdunkelt
[Musik]
guckt mal also ich finde das macht schon
immer so den unterschied warum dann
torten nicht einfach nur langweilig
aussehen sondern so richtig das ist das
i tüpfelchen der token kunst der kommt
kurz zur seite und dann kann ich meine
blüht und aussortieren beziehungsweise
färben die haben jetzt noch gar keine
werbung aber ich muss mir erst die hände
waschen sonst werden sie grün
wir essen übrigens hier gerade die reste
des polo tsunami korens ich hatte noch
so viele polo tsunami soße übrig dass
wir uns seit fünf tagen von nichts
anderem mehr
ok wo lamy und gemüse schaut echt so ein
bisschen verstärkung für den tag wisst
ihr ich nasche im video
das habe ich echt noch nie gemacht zumal
hier nämlich so ein bisschen rosa
jetzt auch einfach direkt rosa machen
können jetzt habe ich eine schöne
farbverlauf
[Musik]
und wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr jetzt
noch zuckerperlen reinsetzen einfach mit
essbaren kleber dann ist die blume
perfekt das war viel kleber
[Musik]
und jetzt hab ich noch was vorbereitet
denn meine ananas bekommt ihr ich für
mich sagen fernsehkoch meine ananas
bekommt jetzt noch ein gesicht das die
zahnbürste und dafür stehe ich jetzt
erstmal zwei augen aus ich nehme jetzt
hier so eine spritztour ganz einfach
weil ich jetzt keine runden kleinen
ausstecher habe hast du so als würden
wir arbeiten jetzt mache ich noch einen
kleinen mund und nehme die spritzt
schule einmal so und dann so jetzt ist
er traurig aber ihr zu sagt plötzlich
aber dass sich bei wir können die torte
zusammensetzen ich glaube es war
schlicht aber ich stehe jetzt noch am
meisten mit zucker schrift etwas mit
zucker schrift ich guck mal wissen uns
denn die lichtpunkte ich noch machen
jetzt geht's ans zusammensetzen der
torte also hier der strom aber da steht
hier oben nicht so gut deswegen werde
ich jetzt tatsächlich was ausstechen und
ihn dann daran setzen
da ist jetzt aus
versteht dann nämlich auch so von ganz
alleine
und bei dem cover steht also diese süße
niedliche art das zeichnen es ist ganz
wichtig dass es gesichtslos wird oder
ein gesicht sieht es aus wenn die augen
ganz groß sind wenn die stirn hoch ist
wie bei einem baby oder bei zwischen
hundewelpen
das heißt sie stehen muss hoch sein also
hier und das gesicht er so gedrückt auf
dem pfad so ein quatsch
süßes knuddel gesicht also werde ich die
augen auch er weiter unten ansetzen
ich muss jetzt nur kurz zu mir drehen
jetzt hier meinen thema in einem
schälchen auftrags am pinsel auf
[Musik]
und hier steche ich jetzt noch rosa
pausbäckchen aus und klebt hier noch an
den mund
[Musik]
mit weißer zucker schrift x ich jetzt
hier noch die lichtpunkte an die augen
[Musik]
und wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr noch die
blümchen dran setzen dann ist es ein
mädchen
ist sie nicht süß die kleine pina colada
okay jetzt sagen nicht so jetzt jemanden
der die torte probieren kann
und ja es tut mir schon manchmal weh die
torten anzuschneiden gerade so wenn sie
so fertig gestellt sind und ich so
absolut keinen anlass dafür habe wenn
ich jetzt jemanden hätte dass ich über
eine geburtstagstorte gefreut hätte wer
ist mir tausendmal lieber aber jetzt
haben wir keinen geburtstag egal machen
wir es kurz nach hawaii party hier in
hawaii party ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ach mensch wird nichts draus aus unserer
hawaii party wenn ich so hawaii sage
denke ich an der arbeit ist das ist die
pina colada wollte ist echt ein flitzer
teller
ich habe jetzt gar kein teller weil die
spülmaschinen läuft so viele planer
erinnert mich natürlich anderen cocktail
ganz gerührt ob der üblich ist schön aus
und ist an alles was ist aber ein
anderes gab die nada und und kokos
genommen eigentlich hätte es auch mehr
nicht
ich habe dort die arena ist unsere kokos
machen
das heißt es jetzt
ich bin gespannt
also was ich echt sagen muss ich mag
fondant orten denn da fondant der held
der praktisch den ganzen geschmack die
ganzen aromen und auch die feuchtigkeit
in der torte also wie so ein
schutzmantel und dann trocknete torte
reicht aus und es gibt jetzt eine so ein
vorteil dass ballack nicht gut schmecken
die schmeckt echt haben ohne witz und
war wissen wie die schmeckt kennt hier
ich glaube jetzt diese schleichwerbung
machen ich muss sich in einem klaren
nein diesmal ganz kurz die kunststoffe
auch drauf dann braucht er sich das
kinderparadies
hinter paradiso schmecken ist der hammer
ich muss sagen ich habe echt zum
verhältnis von kuchen und creme gewählt
er weniger krämer kuchen
aber man kann die creme schicht deutlich
noch erhöhen auch als ich bin so perfekt
weil es sich nicht mächtig also die
sowieso ein marmorkuchen mit so bisschen
füllung wenn ihr das ganze eher rockige
haben wollt könnt ihr auch gerne noch
mehr creme aber ich bin zu perfekt und
ich habe hier innen drin so ein ananas
körtge man von sta travel card und es
ist auch echt könnte deine hand benutzen
zum festhalten
dann drehte ich finde es echt perfekt an
die buttercreme so ganz dünn und die das
anders gehört mir manche menschen die
von noch nicht essen aber hier dazu aber
wirklich weil die pina colada die ich
eher so fruchtig frisch oder die ananas
und dann noch die süße von einem wunder
richtig lecker und ich habe auch dass
annas gehörten nicht zu süß gemacht und
die buttercreme habe ich auch zucker
reduziert also ich finde auch mal kann
denn fondant auf jeden fall mit essen
opfern dann oder von bord
das gehört genauso gemacht wie lemon
könnten überhaupt mit brotaufstrich
holst dir kurz allein lässt als
brotaufstrich des level gehört das haben
wir euch wieder als tauglich gemacht
aber diese dieses ananas gehört wenn ich
mal ganz kurz probieren das habe ich
auch so noch nie gesehen ja das könnte
man das rezept sage mal und ich hab das
rezept seiner gemacht im video
es hat ja mehrere etappen und dieses
ananas gehört und das bisschen richtig
lecker warte ich frings dir
mein gott du bist ja auch für nichts zu
schade 70 mal cool aber allem wenn du in
den kühlschrank
dann kommt nicht zum lachen das glasklar
wie das wird die politik wenn ihr bei
den hotel habt jetzt folgt die zuschauer
dem unterland ich habe so viele freunde
die im hotel haben es also genau wissen
als und am tisch zu risiko macht mich
ganz klar wo ich liebe ihn über alles
sollen wir jetzt gemacht sah mehr mit
dem deckel mit der ananas drauf tja und
so schaut die konsistenz jetzt auch eine
abgekühlt von ansturm auftaktstück nähe
ganz wenig er liegt und weil ich musste
für die torte moses soll das sein
ungelogen ist killer in you go zonen
möchtest das kennt auch gehzeit mit
deinem es tut mir leid ich es jetzt
einfach tut mir leid das ist so ein
beispiel was ist auch sagen können das
sind geschmacklich erinnert an abfinden
muss wahrlich kein zurück und ganz wenig
wenn ich also morath feiert das an
alaska feiert auf die torte hoffe ich
das ist cool feinstaub haben wir bei der
heute annabi ich stamme deutschland ist
stabil stabil
chinakohl aber echte wiener colada
gesprächen also macht die zarte doch
gerne nach ich glaube wirklich dass
viele sich über diese torte als
geburtstagsgeschenk freuen würden
porsche school übrigens bugs für mich
niemand eine geburtstagstorte
das war ein seiten min also viel spaß
für land machen schreibt mir gerne in
welche torte als nächstes sehen wollt
vielleicht tatsächlich eine lego torte
oder einem indiens torte beim vollen
weist das so gelb und noch einmal
gedacht das sieht aus wie lego und
minions ich habe gedacht jungs an lego
unsere mir auch anleger und ich hab auch
rein also torten wünsche gerne in die
kommentare viel spaß beim nachbacken und
bis zum 9
da ist ich da haben wir gemerkt wie
waren sie ja der buttercreme einfach und
dieses lokal fehlt noch ein bisschen
mehr macht als macht's möglich schreibt
sie ins rezept rein weil ich habe auch
noch kriegen übrig ich schreibe 1 5 mm
krämer ich musste dieses mal gar nicht
lügen hatte kommt mit einem engen für
schritt
[Musik]